welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens honestly I love Megan
the stallion in episode three episode
three was Chef kiss but episode 4 is by
far my favorite so far we get so much
wrong we get the Mystic Arts demons and
spooky dimensions and how many times can
we save me Fisto our new rock stars so
we're introduced to so many new
characters and there's so many theories
that we had so let's try and point out
all the little details that you could
have easily missed because there's a lot
additionally if you haven't yet are
great Partners over epic hero shop just
released their green Justice merch line
inspired by She-Hulk it's got several
different t-shirt designs including the
newest limited edition latest Obsession
shirt Lady Justice they're also dropping
lines inspired by the house of dragon
and or rings of power in the coming
weeks when you purchase one of these
shirts you get an opportunity to get a
shout out from boss mtni on inside
Marvel so it's pretty sick deal nice
shirt nice shout out let's get into it
orange juice to Donnie Blaze played by
Rhys Coro who's the husband to the
director cat Coro remember the poster
from the trailer that got us all in a
tizzy you can see it right there I
definitely was one of many that said it
was Donny I definitely did not say it
was Johnny I never said it
let's wipe it from our memories he's
levitating by a rope you can see it
disconnects there he's sparking fire
from his hand Contraption how many
close-up magicians can we get into the
MCU now we later learned Donnie was a
former student of the Mystic Arts he's
now performing for a crowd of unenthused
folks bummer and I really really hate
him already because he referred to
Shakespeare's Billy shakes which is why
we can also see who they sort of favored
him after he has a B for his last name
on his necklace along with the raven
bird skull necklace looking like Khan
shoes all the occult jewelry this dude's
a poser we also learned this is LA's
Mystic Castle which can easily be a nod
to the private club that is the Magic
Castle that features a ton of magicians
and variety art performances but this
Mystic Castle has a ton of old relics
and posters giving it a very spooky Vibe
we're also introduced to Madison with
two ends and one y but it's not anything
it's spelled like this she's played by
very funny Patty Guggenheim behind
Madison we see the portal open and
there's a head on his bike a torch in
front of some older looking homes and
what looks like a torture box either
this is Hell or someone's pillaging I
have a theory of what this might be and
we'll get more into this later I promise
we'll come right back to it we get that
sweet sweets Sopranos opening song wake
up this morning by Alabama three we're
now in Kathmandu Nepal which we know the
karmotage is in I really want The
Sopranos version for Wong and the other
students are the Mystic Arts Maybe
please just make him a spin-off and if
it's like The Sopranos I'll eat it up we
get a better look at that room we saw in
episode 2. it resembles one of the rooms
in camataj we saw in the Multiverse of
Madness Wong is relaxing he's got his TV
his tea and a biscuit holding it like a
little cigar we know our Wong can get
down once Madison drops in with a heart
we see Wong is watching season five
episode 12 of The Sopranos long-term
parking this episode is exactly where
they kill Adriana and yes it's very sad
she goes on to mention how she got the
cometage we know from later a talking
boat helped Madison escape a lava pit in
exchange for six drops of her blood we
also get more information she was pushed
into a fire land the Demon's name that
she made a deal with was Jake so we've
got goblins Fireland talking goat and
some damn near blood ritual but y'all I
don't know if I want to say it but it's
looking like she was sent to a fiery
nether realm of Hell AKA mephisto's
round one knowing Madison she was pretty
intoxicated she probably called the
quasi-looking Satan the talking goat
when it was a man with goat-like
features plus Mephisto just wants to
enslave human Souls by any means
necessary so it wouldn't surprise me he
lied and was like yeah sure call me Jake
two Mephisto is known to resemble Satan
act like Satan and his realm reflects
hell hence the fire land as Madison
called it it was probably just
mephisto's realm three and mother of
demons we know Lilith was sent to hell
and became the partner to Mephisto and
she can conjure up goblins according to
the Marvel Zombies the book of angels
Demons of various monstrosities so those
could have been goblins that she fought
it's crazy to think they just introduce
a piece of me pistol like this but in
reality the writers could have been
depicting hell with other similar
characters like Baphomet or Belasco but
you know the folks at new rockstars love
Mephisto and what a fun callback it
would be in the future if it is mephista
we're in Jen's kitchen which in my 30s I
pray I have a kitchen this nice jazz or
UCLA magnet and a mug in the cabinet two
more lamps so like seven lamps in total
in this one apartment Jen and the Riders
know what they're doing when she breaks
the fourth wall here this time
acknowledging Wong's intro to the
episode would make us so happy when in
reality I think it's just super funny
that Wong is suing Donnie Blaze because
Madison spoiled season 5 episode 12 for
all of us now I don't know if I got into
it before but Jen's dad Morris Walters
was a sheriff in the comics so I
wouldn't be surprised if he was possibly
retired now and just knew how to take
extra precautions including hiding a
dead body also I get it you're a Hulk
but living alone 101 lock your doors Jen
that's weird we get a glimpse of
she-hulk's computer with her daily task
and before y'all ask why she has a
picture of herself on her desktop I do
it too because if I ever need to change
my profile pic on anything professional
I can as soon as possible either way we
see the immense amount of flagged emails
and tasks that need to be done there's
so much here and I'll just try to keep
it brief and go through it really
quickly you see finalized blonsky's
injunction an injunction is a court
order requiring a person to do or cease
doing a specific action so this is
probably wrapping up the whole you can't
turn into Abomination ever again rule
along with some other stuff prepare
guidance language for Blonsky inhibitor
which speaks for itself call a Mill's
parole officer now I have my theories
that this will be Val but it's all still
up in the air ordering highlighters from
Supply clerk purple and green clearly
because those are She-Hulk colors I'm
sure the supply curve could also be
anyone at GLK H but I wanted to be Andy
who was featured as the office assistant
at glkh in the comics meet Nikki at the
bathroom 1147 the poop bathroom schedule
summer associate interviews a sad face a
summer associate is a lost Junior who
works for a big Law Firm over the summer
and makes what equates to an associate
lower level lawyer at a firm salary
during that time thank you Lauren this
was from my best friend Lauren who's a
lawyer Buy and read how to make friends
and influence people there is a book
called How to Win Friends and Influence
People by Dale Carnegie a self-help book
offering advice on conversation Styles
how to make friends and increase your
popularity something I need for the
cases featuring ruina and Pete is the
nod to Megan the stallion whose last
name is Pete also sign up for Big and
Tall membership probably just a nod to
Big and Tall outfits compiled as
positions for leaver's Brynn which could
be a nod to Stan Lee and John Brynn who
wrote and Drew for Sensational She-Hulk
file Discovery request for craft and
solay a potential nod to David Anthony
craft who wrote Savage She-Hulk and
Charles sule run of the She-Hulk that
actually is my favorite run of She-Hulk
as Charles Soules go look at it and the
only thing she's finished is creating a
dating profile she's using matcher and
it looks like Tinder peep the logo
similarities once she's logged in we see
her name pronouns and location we've got
another QR code because the show loves
them but for the basics she's looking
for a man between the ages of 30 45 they
can range from 5 6 to 7 7-Eleven all
within a 25 mile radius and I know it
breaks my heart too I'm not what she's
looking for oh once Wong appears to find
out that Donnie Blaze was yes a former
student of the
of them but was kicked kicked after one
week after summoning three kegs and his
former fraternity brother to Karma Taj
compared to kaisilius and the zealots
who were former trainers of the Mystic
Arts who beheaded the librarian and
escaped in the first Doctor Strange they
made what Donnie did not so bad Wong
says this practicing the Mystic odds
with a proper training not only
endangers people it risks untethering
the material and astral planes this is
probably referencing in Doctor Strange
when he started meddling with the
temporal manipulations Donnie doesn't
have the eye of agamoto but the sling
ring can open any dimensional portal in
the universe so it can stir up a lot of
chaos also this is what I never
recognized which is worth noting that
long though up to date on all the pop
culture references from Earth is still
blind to Common Earth rules which is
insane to me you think you'd learn from
The Sopranos or at least ways to evade
it but he's he just genuinely doesn't
know laws if you want skin so good it
could be CGI the folks at geology are
here to help geology is a 13-time
award-winning skincare company that
creates simple effective personalized
skin care products see the link in this
video's description click that and take
the 30 second quiz tell geology all
about your skin and their team of
dermatologists will design a regimen
just for you that shifts directly to
your door knock knock it's theology
their products are great for whatever
you're worried about acne dark eye
circles or wrinkles you'll be set a
30-day trial set that's easy to
incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skincare or a seasoned
expert like myself their fancy eye cream
is a great way to avoid those dark
circles under your eyes after a night of
partying like me or working late like me
we're just trying to find all the QR
codes in an She-Hulk episode oh my God
these are all me geology makes it easy
to take care of your skin without having
to do a ton of homework the ramping up
to release a brand new hair care
products like an all-new co-wash shampoo
and conditioner be sure to let them know
you're interested when you fill out the
Diagnostics so you can be the first to
know when it releases they're offering a
great deal right now you can get 70 off
I said 70 off on their 30 day five piece
trial kit head to geology.com to get 70
off on your 30-day trial when you use
the code rockstar70 or just click the
link below that's geology.com promo code
rockstar70 to save 70 off on your 30-day
trial Take it Away Jessica so now Wong
and She-Hulk are teaming up to make sure
no unlicensed person can practice the
Mystic Arts again and of course we get a
shout out to the book of Shanti the book
from Multiverse of Madness the book that
granted a sorcerer anything they needed
anything any Juan's got cards love the
class they find he also refers to the
magic as cheap human tricks which takes
me back to Jimmy Woo's magic tricks in
one division it wasn't cheap he
practiced really hard we're back at the
legalese bar and grill and Jen is still
working then this weirdo man tries to
pick up Nikki and Jen literally both of
them he's playing married guy the
actor's name is Brit George this scene
is too weird to ignore which is why I
think this might be someone's dad a
married father someone like leapfrog the
two actors resemble one another I might
be wrong on this but it might be our
introduction to leapfrog's Dad we know
in the comics Eugene Don's father's
costume as the crime-fighting Frog man
and his dad was the bad guy though we
switched up the costume Donnie and maybe
we're keeping the same father-son
Dynamic Nikki mentions hetero life is
grim when swiping on Jen's matcher and
to that I say
it is very true also not shipping folks
immediately that look she gives Jen
after saying there are plenty of
non-gross people out there for you to
date okay Nikki I see you you got a
Christmas Shield because girl get in
line we're at the door of Cornelius P
Willows owner and curiosity curator of
Mystic Castle Cornelius is played by
Leon Lamar and is sort of Donny's hype
man is quoted by She-Hulk he's got some
pristine vintage stuff here like the
Harry Keller magician poster the Vintage
Houdini poster the prince of magicians
poster the old school Sundial and all
the Vintage lamps and old wallpaper this
place is spooky as hell when Wong
creates his own sort of Fireball it's
really made of the Ring similar to his
whip he can toss these like balls of
flame which we see done fighting the
demons later he's also used this move
when fighting Wanda and Multiverse of
Madness Donny's pants also just say sex
over and over and over again I hate this
guy I want the pants though pants are
cool we're at Finley's meet drink and
sports bar Jen's on a date with a
freaking ass hat who not only is
checking other people out but is
actively on matcher it has the same
swipe sound that Jan heard earlier in
cornelius's shop and I also hate that we
drink the same IPA we're back in court
it's Wong vs Donnie Blaze our judge
judge Hannah played by Suzanne salny
Donny's lawyers Hank Sanderson and his
height man the owner of the domestic
Castle is also there I don't know if
they did this on purpose but they each
assemble a different famous magician and
Illusionist and if you're my mom you're
probably asking how do they constantly
know exactly where to go with those dank
sling Rings we know from Thor Ragnarok
there's an incantation spell to find
someone that has small modifications if
you're as guardian I'm sure Wong who has
read every book knows how to do it from
memory he conjures up our amazing
witness Madison who's still partying
whom I love she's so so supportive Juan
crazy in one of the Taoist Gods before
Madison gives her testimony our girls
fixing to finally take a real break and
jump into the dating pool of She-Hulk
she's back on matcha with a new photo
and name as She-Hulk it's playing Zoom
by Jesse you know the song from Tick
Tock it's truly a Bop and Anthem I can't
do the dance oh she is swiping right on
everyone Scott the dog lover Grant the
jump rope King Nick the DJ Noah the
director truck the local cutie AKA
Jessica gal's husband truck Torrance in
with their cat Admiral we see Alan the
TV host of Destiny at the news who we
saw in the latest episode first date
with Derek played by David Otunga now
David went to Harvard for law as a
professional wrestler in real life so
truly a win-win for most but Derek pass
he's wild second dated with Noah the
director and I'd pass two now this guy
is super sketchy we don't know what his
name is yet he's obsessed with her being
indestructible and a Hulk this guy could
have been the guy that hired The
Wrecking Crew he's also wearing a gold
band and red ring just like Drake offs
and black widow so he could have a
connection to maybe the remaining widows
and we know Jessica gal had a soft spot
for Black Widow a while ago we get to
hopefully the last guy our third play by
Michael cereal who we've seen Jen
talking to in bed in the trailers gem
plays it smooth and fast and I like it
go get those fries girl we're back at
the Mystic castle with Donnie blaze a
new volunteer amberlay played by Carolyn
Henry I guess weekly he's been
transporting people to different places
and they're just left stranded Emily was
about to be stranded at this truck stop
he conjures up a dove that lays an egg
in her hand hatching into a demon then
Donny conjures up a portal kicking the
demon and the dove back into it now we
see a better shot of what's in the hole
later and I think this is Marvel's limbo
it does resemble the demons that come
out of limbo and in the comics it's
ruled by balasco who I mentioned earlier
could have set Madison to Wong because
was a super powerful sorcerer Once Upon
a Time so it's possible I also like the
idea that Donny's just sending them to
different spooky Dimensions every time
by accident so I'd like to keep them
separated okay back on track Wong is a
fan of This Is Us and I hate to be the
Madison of the group but this is Jack's
treason after the funeral and it's so so
sad I think this is what made him late
to the trial with a male because his
eyes were a little red from crying Juan
conjured up these sort of knuckle blades
similar to the ones in Star Wars the
vibro knucklers and it's also serving
this one scene from Mission Impossible
that we all love Jen breaks down having
a change in a She-Hulk in front of
everyone at work for her first day at
glkh which is embarrassing she didn't
even have shoes on this line he says the
Jen is so funny to me also Wong you've
been interrupted like twice now and you
should know how pure rating it is ew Jen
shoes I don't know what it is about
demon-like creatures but when they're
hurt they secrete this green mucus it's
kind of similar to the tentacled
creatures in Shang Chi when they were
sliced or the guts that fell on the
woman in Thor Ragnarok when they slice
of the fire dragon some Ghostbuster
slime [ __ ] I think Wong is opening a
portal near Wonder Gore Mountain Mount
Wonder Gore is an ancestral Mountain
surrounded by dark magic the location is
still a major Marvel location though
Scarlet Witch destroyed the darkhorn
castle see Jen using the lesson she
learned from Bruce in the first episode
look at the air on that jump I think
it's funny that the bat is trying to
chew on her hand and it's not even
making a dent when the demon is thrown
against the wall it evolves to a bigger
size demon it literally leveled up what
I do know in Hellstorm season 1 episode
2 we learned demons normally grow
stronger once possessing a human or
feeding off their energy and negative
responses and Jen is pissed to be
missing this day and she's being very
vocal about it Jen's back to her date
who's reading bath feminist by Roxanne
gay a series of essays exploring being a
feminist while loving things that don't
allow with feminist ideology when she
picks him up it's so cartoony it's
literally giving Jessica Rabbit and
Roger Rabbit he kicks the lamp over Jen
doesn't care she's got other things on
her mind it's the next morning the
morning after nothing makes me happier
than Belinda Carlisle's Heaven is a
place on Earth it's a new day we're just
happy as Jen she made fresh squeezed
orange juice breakfast oh I love her I
would love to wake up to Jen she gets a
text from Nikki and I love when shows do
this with the text just visibly showing
it to us Titania is back baby she's in
the news the last two episodes she's
been mentioned on the news trying to get
out of the courtroom fight in episode
one the title who we saw covering Jen's
last episode mentions that titanium is
free of all charges also with the
hashtag free Titania in the background
when Arthur wakes up he's wondering
where She-Hulk is not recognizing Jen is
She-Hulk something similar to this
happened in the comics where Jen went to
bed with a model and before the model
woke up she changed back to the She-Hulk
Arthur dips out not expecting Jen to
change out of She-Hulk form and there's
immediately a knock at the door it's a
damn process server Titania trademark
She-Hulk and it's so petty and I love it
I eat this stuff up we see her legal
name is Mary McFerrin like it is in the
comics at the end we get new courtroom
illustrations Madison basically signs
her life away to Jake Jen as She-Hulk
cleaning up the demon goo from her body
Wong putting Donnie into the mirror
Dimension he's fine the mid-credit scene
is Wong and Madison enjoying the first
time Jack and Rebecca say I love you and
this is us I don't watch this as us you
guys I truly don't don't think I do I
just watched lot of bits and pieces and
nothing's wrong with watching this is
this it's just like it is so sad and I
don't I I don't have time to crack
Madison wrapped up in a nice comfy
jacket eating popcorn sharing different
Liquors with Wong they are so cute and
Juan's favorite drink is a gin and tonic
I love this relationship I can't wait to
see more of this please give me more of
this that's everything I spotted in the
fourth episode of She-Hulk follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
let's make Heaven a place on Earth God
damn it's hot as [ __ ] here God damn I
gotta get out
[Music]
thank you
[Music]